[Musik]
eins ist vollkommen klar das ist der
einzige fall wo nicht das kreuz der frau
im mittelpunkt steht sondern die uniform
des herrn absolut im mittelpunkt es geht
nämlich um den ball offiziere und um die
internationalität in oder bei diesen
beiden es gibt wahnsinnig viele menschen
die jedes jahr wieder von ganz weit her
kommen um bei diesem ball dabei zu sein
eins ist klar es gibt viele offiziere
auf der ganzen welt und die kommen hier
treffen sich zum austausch und einige
von diesen den offizieren habe ich
natürlich auch vors mikrofon bekommen
aber ursprünglich wahrscheinlich dann
nicht einmal merken
juni vom california bin ich ja hier habe
ich etwas schon unsere wie sagt man das
so sei die optionale und da das heißt
also ich habe eine erfurter der
im krieg revolution
wie sagt man nie vor in der
revolutionary road und wir haben so ein
programm das haben können so das ist
eine schweizweit ich kann und wofür
steht der uniform
ja das frage ich mich auch wie kriegen
die wir müssen sie nicht selber bezahlen
wie die haben wir kaum noch nehmen was
wir kriegen und da haben sie mit stolz
sind sie schon öfters tag gewesen wenn
beide offiziere
nein das ist mein erster mal und wie
kommt das daher kommen
ich habe schon öfters darüber gehört und
wollte mal mitkommen
warum was gefällt ihnen hier die leute
das ist so viele leute hier fünf so
viele andere städte länder und so hab
ich gern mit anderen leuten
es ist das erste mal dabei sein zum
dritten mal bereits und wir freuen uns
jedes jahr wiederum bekommen jedes jahr
wieder ein wiederholungstäter sozusagen
warum
ja wenn man schon die gelegenheit in der
hofburg an einer offiziers bau dann muss
man das machen ist mit abstand der
schönste baum soll auf der ganzen welt
bin ich überzeugt war hier
[Musik]